et on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui
comme chaque mardi à mes côtés marie
roger biloa du groupe afrique
international bonjour marie roger d'un
joueur a fait face avoue bruno daroux de
la rédaction de france 24 bonjour brunoh
bonjour assaël constructif
substantielle rarement on aura entendu
pareille qualificatifs dans la bouche
des négociateurs russes depuis qu'a
commencé le 24 février l'invasion de
l'ukraine c'est bien la première fois
qu'on perçoit un signe encourageant du
côté du kremlin les discussions avec
leurs homologues ukrainiens à istanbul
ont semble-t-il porté leurs fruits
moscou se dit prête à réduire de manière
drastique les autorités à kiev la
capitale et cherniff dans le nord
écouter
le ministère de la défense de la
fédération de russie a décidé de réduire
radicalement l'activité militaire en
direction de kiev et de tchernihiv pour
accroître la confiance mutuelle et créer
les conditions nécessaires pour
poursuivre les négociations
faut-il croire les russes marie roger
biloa -qui déjà la veille du week-end
disait vouloir concentrer leur offensive
sur le don bas messieurs que l'on
jette tout ça me rappelle un épisode il
se passer en 85 et la petite omayra
sanchez je ne sais pas si vous vous en
souvenez c'était une petite fille en
colombie après un tremblement de terre
une éruption volcanique en fait qui
s'est retrouvé piégé dans une étendue
d'eau et qu'on voulait sauver alors on a
eu beaucoup de mobilisation les secours
extérieurs mais il les secours étaient
mal préparées ou voix elle n'arrivait
pas à la sauver et on a eu droit en
direct pendant des jours et des vies à
l'agonie de cette petite fille qui a
fini par mourir voilà et c'est un peu
l'impression qu'on a depuis le début de
cette crise évidemment les russes
pensaient que ce serait rapide mais
voilà est ce qu'on a au moins tout le
moins un mois après tout ça on en est
encore compter les coûts à regarder des
millions 10 millions de déplacés ou
d'exil et lève la ville de marioupol qui
détruit les villes au fur et à mesure
qu'ils sont détruites à l'offensive
généralisée
reeti à un ralentissement c'est pas par
l'action des alliés et des les alliés le
camp occidental c'est plus par
les problèmes logistiques connaît
l'armée russe est donc aujourd'hui on
nous dit c'est d une avancée formidable
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé
on nous dit déjà eu sa vie derrière la
négociation ou de la bonne volonté ce
qui n'est en réalité qu'une déconvenue
absolument parce que là le sait il s'est
rien passé du tout parce que tout ce qui
peut être décidée aujourd'hui à istanbul
bailleur doit être validé par poutine et
on sait déjà les premiers signes sont
négatifs c'est ce que croit ou c'est ce
que semble croire en tout cas également
sur la même ligne que vous les
américains écoutez donc anthony blinken
voilà
il y à ce que dit la russie ce que fait
la russie ce qui nous intéresse et ce
qu'elle fait en l'occurrence elle
brutalise une crème je n'ai rien vu qui
puisse suggérer que les négociations
avancent efficacement en russie nous ne
voyons vraiment pas de signe sérieux
mais si l'ukraine conclu qu'il y à des
signaux positifs c'est bien et nous
soutenons ceux là
ils auraient pris ce risque là les les
russes y compris d'ailleurs d'infliger
peut-être à un démenti rouault turquie
veulent voir évidemment une une percée
diplomatique remarquable ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui bruno daroux oui alors
cela dit on peut reconnaître quand même
au président turc recep tayyip erdogan
d'avoir réussi quand même un joli coup
parce que même si effectivement je suis
d'accord faut rester quand même
extrêmement prudente sur prudent sur les
avancées d'aujourd'hui on va y revenir
c'est quand même la première fois
effectivement qu'il ya un peu de deux
substances de part et d'autre c'est à
dire que très certainement effectivement
à cause du fait que l'armée russe est en
train de s'embourber notamment dans la
partie nord autour de kiev en ukraine
elle profite effectivement ses
bombardements sur marioupol par exemple
ou encore kharkiv mais quand même 35
jours après le début du conflit
très peu de villes il n'y a eu que la
ville de carson et encore ça ne se passe
pas très bien mais aucune grande ville
n'a été prise donc en termes d'objectifs
stratégiques et militaires de l'armée
russe et bien c'est plutôt quand même
une situation extrêmement compliquée ça
explique effectivement que les russes
ont fait de la petite concession
effectivement il va falloir voir si ça
se manifeste sur le terrain on a vu
aujourd'hui des chars russes qui ont
commencé à regagner la biélorussie qui
donc ont reculé le front autour de kiev
qui est qu'ils n'ont jamais réussi à
encercler totalement à cause d'ailleurs
de la bonne défense de l'armée
ukrainienne des images qui ont été
documentés atteste que certains chars
russes sont repartis en biélorussie mais
enfin là encore il faut voir si ces
massifs si c'est réel est aussi la ville
de tchernihiv plus au nord qui était un
peu à un point de passage à mobiliser
d'un point de vue routier qui a été en
partie évacué donc il ya cette
concession du côté russe mais on peut
comprendre effectivement la très grande
prudence vis-à-vis d'un interlocuteur
qui on le sait manille le mensonge c'est
tout peut-être pour gagner du temps
néanmoins je crois qu'il faut retenir
que ces négociations qui sont
effectivement un peu plus substantiel on
va peut-être venir aussi culotté
ukrainien sur leurs qualités mais il se
passe quand même quelque chose parce que
effectivement le plan de vladimir
poutine ne se déroule pas du tout comme
prévu même si ce plan s'est marié en jeu
ce plan ne se déroule pas comme prévu
c'est clair et pour ce faire une
blitzkrieg
c'est raté mais c'est lui qui dicte
quand même tout l'agenda c'est à dire
aujourd'hui on en est à on est pendus à
ses lèvres qu'est ce qu'ils pensent
est-ce que qu'est-ce qui est dans sa
tête comment il va réagir si les armes
sont s'ils allaient passe par la pologne
est ce que maintenant il paraît qu'il va
mettre il va utiliser des armes
chimiques
on espère que non est ce que ces larmes
clairement fin c'est lui qui dicte
l'agenda donc lui l'agresseur c'est lui
la grue est là mais en même temps on
peut rien faire c'est à dire si jamais
on
j'essaie de dire ce que il y à une
impuissance
allez assez clair
s'ils
manifestent et dramatique du camp
occidental vis-à-vis de cette agression
on a quand même fait croit à une crème
qu'on pourrait la protéger vis-à-vis de
son voisin russe biden avait été assez
clair dès le début plusieurs reprises
mais n'a jamais dit à l'ukraine allait
mourir pour kiev je parle maintenant
mais la situation qui a amené cette
guerre c'était quand même de dire algren
bon c'est demain de maintenir cette
mentalité de guerre froide comme 10 de
chinois
de financer massivement l'armement
krainer on se souvient de cet épisode
trempe qui faisait du chantage à elle
inscrit à l'époque pour obtenir une
condamnation eu un procès contre son
rival
allemand qui permet aussi à l'ukraine
aujourd'hui résister voilà donc on lui a
fait croire n'avoue bâti une ambiance
militaire que voilà on vous donne de
l'argent vous équipe on va vous protéger
vis à vis de la russie mais aujourd'hui
les ukrainiens meurent par milliers le
pays est détruit et on est loin loin
loin du cessez le feu ce qui est le plus
important c'est un cessez le feu on en
est loin
pas qu'il à fait d'accord parce que fait
car on sait très bien pourquoi c'est pas
tellement une question d'impuissance des
occidentaux savent très bien que s'ils
interviennent directement registre du
creps d'une escalade du clairet ben oui
mais là on part vers
guerre mondiale oui voilà mais par
contre s'il ya eu quand même y compris
au cours des dernières semaines d
armement très nombreux qui ont été
fournies à l'ukraine qui avait déjà été
fournis auparavant enfants qui ont été
fortement accélérée qui visiblement aide
quand même missiles sol-air notamment
pas les missiles sol air il ya aussi des
drones l'amendé des drones de nuit qui
sont reliés d'ailleurs un système
satellitaire d'être lus par elon musk
chez j'ai lu ça aujourd'hui qui
permettent en fait au système interne
est de continuer à fonctionner malgré
les coupures puisque sa place par
satellite et donc à ces drones ripd âge
qui en dit des jouets fait vraiment
obligés ans dénonce à tous et nancy
salle annexe de la mairie comment non
non c'est ça le problème ça n'empêche
pas le destructeur construction du pays
avant ces deux là dessus a bien la tête
mais quand je disais de la concernant
les objectifs russe poutine n'a pas
réussi son coup il voulait aussi n'a pas
réussi mais il va peut-être réussir il
va réussir à obtenir d'hassan chose il
va arrêter quand il aura obtenu ce
qu'ils voulaient mais bon peut-être
marioupol voilà et merci de mourir la
transition bruno daroux parce qu'il faut
dire que côté ukrainien ont tenté de
répondre aux exigences de moscou en
consentant à stature neutre pas
d'alliance militaire ni de base
étrangère sur son sol moyennant edéa
protection venant de garant
internationaux écouter
qui nous voulons un mécanisme
international de garanties de sécurité
ou les pays garants agirons d'une
manière similaire à l'article numéro 5
de l'otan
on peut lire ça de deux manières c'est à
la fois une énorme concession faite aux
riches mais aussi peut-être un mode de
contourner le renoncement de rejoindre
l'otan parce que tout de même c'est
malgré tout un sanglant d'articles 5 qui
s'appliquerait à aa donc oui alors là
pour le coup est d'accord avec marie
roger c'est à dire que tout simple on
est sur la table a été entendu par les
négociateurs russes que 5 c'est la
solidarité défensive 1 pour ceux qui la
regardent oui alors qu on pensait
vladimir produit parce que finalement
l'article au sein de l'otan ça veut dire
en gros quand un pays de l'alliance est
attaqué tous les autres tombent sur
l'agresseur donc l'avenir poutine il va
pts et 10 rebonds bac tu es très bien
donc vous êtes ne vous n'êtes pas dans
l'otan mais en même temps il ya ceux il
ya ce mécanisme de sécurité qui en plus
tel qu'il est proposé paraît un peu
un peu surréaliste parce que voir les
états unis et la chine être les parents
mais enfin néanmoins ccc poser l'idée on
comprend bien on comprend bien l'idée
sire que le crédit on veut bien être
neutre mais en cas d'agression on veut
être protégé comment vladimir poutine
va-t-il réagir à ça effectivement la rue
du il faut attendre il faut attendre
s'arrêtent en même temps à la sauce
ukrainienne c'est vraiment
c'est c'est être dans l'otan sans être
dans l'otan bien sûr que vladimir
poutine va refuser regarder ce qu'on
présentait comme la première avancée
c'est à dire l'obtention d'un corridor
humanitaire été refusée par guti ne vous
rendez compte donc pourquoi vous croyez
qu'il va accents tantôt ce sont les
ukrainiens qui ont refusé parce qu'ils
parce qu'en fait les rues étaient
presque vides voilà c'était des faux
corridors humanitaires ont fait une
série d'ailleurs mené tout droit vers
manzini croirait poutine disait quand
même si vous voulez que je refasse ses
corridors il faudrait qu'ils arrêtent de
résister voilà qu'ils déposent les armes
mais évidemment donc ça veut dire non
ils ont refusé donc c'est il est dans
une position d'un transmet alors qu'ils
ont fait c'est lui qui mène l'agenda
mais en fait il est quand même
aujourd'hui 35 jours après et
contrairement à ce qu'ils pensent
évidemment dans une position beaucoup
plus fragile à cause des sanctions si on
n'a pas parlé m'enfin ça ça joue aussi
et ça commence à jouer un rôle sur la
population russe et donc potentiellement
sur la stabilité de son régime à cause
de la résistance de l'armée ukrainienne
et peut-être aussi de la mauvaise
organisation de l'armée russe parce que
il ya ça aussi il est en train d'offrir
au monde le live bagla rennais le
spectacle d'une armée russe qui en fait
en terme de logistique de communication
etc ne fonctionne pas très bien sans
parler d'un moral qui n'est pas vraiment
hyper motivés de dix ans pour aller
effectivement taper s'il s'est affaiblie
lui même parce qu'on le sait pour être
un leader fort il faut être respectée ce
qu'il y'a pas là un problème y compris
vis-à-vis de ses propres ailes et la
chine voire même de son propre peuple
oui c'est à dire si on regarde sur le
plan militaire mais moi je suis quand
même surprise que vu cette situation vu
l'enlisement vu tous les problèmes que
qu'on connaît maintenant sur la conduite
de la guerre ex terrain c'est lui qui a
même qui décide ce qui va se passer
c'est parce que vous le savez on
comprend bien que les américains veut
maintenir la pression en finale il
maintient la pression
dès le départ je peux pas intervenir et
on comprend pourquoi il y à un mur
totalement infranchissables cris et la
guerre la bombe nucléaire et donc
poutine c'est qu'il a une marge de
manoeuvre encore très
ya deux trois semaines sa marge de
manoeuvre se réduit parce que sur le
terrain militairement ça se passe pas si
bien alors après ce qui est intéressant
aussi qui n'a pas vraiment été abordée
aujourd'hui d'heure dans les
négociations manière très vague ils ont
ils ont parlé de négociations
bilatérales entre kiev et moscou pendant
15 ans oui alors voilà territoire mais
là on voit bien que l'ukraine pour
l'heure en tout cas le voile à kiev ne
lâche pas la crimée et encore moins
évidemment le don base donc est-ce que
c'est comme la nature d'un rapport de
forces sur le terrain ne lâche pas mais
quand un pays dit on va discuter pendant
15 ans quel sera le salut final de tel
ou tel territoire ça revient peut-être
quand même à le lâcher moi je trouve que
le président hélène ski qualité oui
cette cécité sur la table voilà je vois
sa routine c'est peut-être
point évoqué la russie ne verrait pas
forcément ma mauvaise a eu le crâne
rejoint l'union européenne vous y croyez
ça alors le mieux aux open ça c'était un
moindre enjeu ce qu'il veut pas depuis
le départ et c'est beaucoup disent
l'ukraine rejoigne l'union européenne
c'est une vitrine démocratique donnés
aux russes dont poutine ne voulait
absolument pas lié paris voulait rien
voulait rien mais au moment de lâcher
quelques trucs maintenant pour avancer
je crois que l'union européenne c'est le
plus inoffensif voilà l'union européenne
surtout que ça c'est l'europe le gros
problème de poutine si on regarde le
prec ce cas les états unis donc l'otan a
le temps l'europe avait des relations
j'allais dire assez convivial très
impliqué on voit la langue avec jusqu'à
la crim effectivement donc bon c'est
quand même beaucoup dégradée depuis
c'est pas le même point de départ que
les états si moscou accepte ses
propositions en tout cas ça veut dire
qu'elle n'a en réalité plus d'autres
options on est bien d'accord ouais mes
choix je crois qu'en fait il faut
séparer l'eau ce qui a été négocié c'est
quand même intéressant ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui même si on n'y est pas
encore frisbey faut rester prudent mais
il ya la question de militaires arrivés
à un cessez le feu ou place-t-on la
ligne de front est ce qu'on gèle les
positions bon il ya toutes ces questions
qui se posent et puis effectivement sur
un plan plus diplomatique donc ce fameux
statut de la neutralité est ce que par
exemple l'ukraine serait un pays neutre
démilitarisé c'est pas obligatoire non
bon voilà le diable va peut-être se
livrent les détaillants l'aide dans les
détails mais il ya quand même un
frémissement je dirais pas une avancée
mais les choses bougent un peu le
révélateur ce sera la rencontre zelensky
poutine que les ukrainiens réclamé que
les russes n'ont pas l'air de vouloir
concédé non
a dit quand même que une peut-être que
désormais ils ne rencontrent non non non
non il l'avait jamais dit non non les
russes n'ont jamais dit ça
attendons le démenti du kremlin qui ne
manquera pas de
les finir
c'est la première fois qu'un négociateur
russe dit qu'une rencontre entre les
deux présidents il n'a pas nommé
talansky les palais jusqu'à nommer
zelensky serait possible jusque là
zelensky demandait rencontré poutine et
poutine n'aurait pour des membres a de
toute façon pour lui c'était un nazi il
faut semer même excuse moi mais il sera
possible qu'en savez c'est une phrase
que je peux dire peut-être le dessin ou
la réponse dans les prochaines heures
qui de roger biloa de bruno daroux avez
raison de le dire aussi des titans est
il dans les mêmes dispositions que ses
négociateurs un d'istanbul ou au
contraire sur une ligne beaucoup plus
dur on le sera peut-être dans les
prochaines minutes un mot du rapport
d'amnesty international pour finale
vient de sortir pour l'année 2000 21
justement en lien avec cette guerre en
ukraine ce rapport qui pointe les
différences de traitement ici en europe
et notamment en france dans l'accueil
des migrants selon qu'ils soient
ukrainiens ou bien d'autres nationalités
afghans par exemple écouter ce qu'en
disait la secrétaire générale ici même
sur france 24
parties du monde
c'est un axe ce qui signifie non
seulement des millions de morts
vers le monde mais ça signifie aussi que
l'économie globale lahm a pu redémarrer
et pendant que tout cela se passait les
grandes compagnies pharmaceutiques
elle a cumulé accumulé vous savez que à
l'heure actuelle on estime que les deux
plus grandes faveurs et moderna ont
accumulé cinq ans 4,1 milliards de
dollars d'intérêts alors là il parlait
des vaccins mais elle est s'est
également exprimé sur la question des
réfugiés pourrait qu'il y avait un deux
poids deux mesures ici en france la
france qui a trouvé en quelques jours
les moyens déployés au moins deux cent
mille places d'hébergement lorsqu en
2016 au sortir de la pire crise on s'en
souvient a observé en méditerranée la
france s'était dite prête à accueillir à
peine dix-huit mille migrants sur les
160000 débarqué sur les côtes
européennes et que devait se répartir
les pays européens comment expliquer ce
deux poids deux mesures marie rosé savez
il ya une chose qui a été très triste
au moment où cette guerre se déclencher
ou vous n'a vu les ukrainiens déjà
faire une distinction entre les
africains les autres les empêcher de
monter dans les gens notamment et et
c'était un choc pour beaucoup
d'africains moment où tout le monde
essaie de sauver sa peau et je ne peux
m'empêcher de faire le parallèle avec un
moment que un événement qui se déroulait
il ya quelques années et quelques
décennies en allemagne où un groupe
d'étudiants venant de côte d'ivoire de
l'université de côte d'ivoire était en
stage en allemagne et les étés se sont
retrouvés en détresse financière parce
que là l'organisation que les a fait
venir nous n'a plus payé ce qu'ils
avaient promis et chacun a écrit à son
ambassade chacun écrit en se disant on a
des problèmes comment on va faire et
notamment aussi l ambassade de côte
d'ivoire eh ben vous savez le
l'ambassadeur de côte d'ivoire est
arrivé il n'a pas fait dans le détail
n'a pas dit vous êtes de telle
nationalité de la nationalité je ne vais
m'occuper que des ivoiriens even
trentaine d'étudiants il a payé une
subvention à tout le monde sans
distinction en disant qu'ils sont tous
des ivoiriens et ben j'étais dans ce
groupe là et jusqu'aujourd'hui et c'est
quelque chose que j'ai pas bu il faut
rendre hommage à l'ambassadeur gomis
paix à son âme il est décédé à quelques
mois eh bien vous voyez ce genre d'état
d'esprit qui pour une chose anodine et
là on est incapable de secourir des gens
qui risquent qui vont vers la mort comme
tout le monde voilà bruno daroux c'est
choquant ou bien il ya un devoir de
solidarité envers un pays proche des
européens moi je prends ça comme un jeu
qui ressemble effectivement à deux poids
deux mesures alors on n'ose pas dire les
choses d'ailleurs un on n'accueille plus
facilement les ukrainiens est tant mieux
d'ailleurs et notamment les cent mille
places parce qu'ils sont européens voilà
parce qu'ils sont comme nous sont blancs
chrétiens entre guillemets je caricature
bien sûr et vous avez cité le chiffre de
2016 les afghans qui aussi sortait quand
même d'un conflit l'été dernier bah
elles n'ont pas été accueillis on a
parlé d'un nouveau problème migratoire
auxquels faisait face l'europe donc
effectivement je n'ai jamais dit
vraiment marre sert le gouvernement
annonce simplement cent mille cent mille
places d'accueil de possibilité de
rester temporairement sur le territoire
français pour les ukrainiens mais en
oubliant de dire et c'est le rôle
d'amnesty international pour le coup que
pour les afghans sans parler le d
afrique et syriens
le conflit et ont la facilité tout tagro
méditer merci bruno merci marie roger
c'est la faim dont va plus loin on se
retrouve nous dans moins de trois
minutes pour un nouveau journal reste
avec nous